Kylie Jenner and Travis Scott's baby  girl can snowboard like a pro the  22-year old beauty mogul took to social  media to flaunt her nearly two-year old  daughter skills on the hills during  their winter wonderland vacation  storming it turns 2 in February but her  talents have clearly come out early as  she went from nailing snowboarding on  the trip to bowling Kylie's shared every  adorable moment from her holiday getaway  with her little one on the gram from her  own sultry photoshoot in the snow  rocking a sexy white jumpsuit to showing  off several of her Chanel and Fendi snow  bunny fashions she even had a little  vino while decorating gingerbread houses  proving Kylie's winter wonderland vacay  is total goals with snow Travis in sight  [Music]